[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday October 31st I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
both virtual and augmented reality are
elements of the metaverse but some
people think AR is the bigger business
opportunity
one company that entered the AR space
pretty early on is Microsoft it unveiled
its Hollow lens headset in 2015 and put
it on sale the next year the device sits
on a user's head like a crown and a
screen over their eyes overlays digital
images onto their view of the real world
but in its efforts to make hololens a
profitable product Microsoft has run up
against a number of stumbling blocks
joining us to discuss what those are and
what it means for Microsoft's prospects
in the metaverse is our Tech reporter
Aaron Tilley hi Aaron thanks for joining
me hey thanks for having me so Aaron can
you just start by explaining what
hololens was originally built for so it
started out as this idea around the
future of gaming consoles and it morphed
as the kind of company shifted and was
placed under
the windows division so it kind of
became both a idea around productivity
as well as gaming it was anything
developers could dream of it as they
brought it out for developers and over
time
um you know consumer adoption they
realized was not going to happen it was
way too expensive and so they kind of
shifted towards the Enterprise selling
to companies and how workers can use
these devices
okay so let's talk a little bit about
the situation now then you know who is
buying hololens there are quite a number
of large corporations using them for
example Mercedes-Benz at U.S service
centers there are technicians wearing
them to help repair uh cars the cars of
their customers I talk to them it's
considerably helped them it's helped
them speed up repair times and then
their single biggest customer here is
the military the US military has this
ambitious plan to
put these smart goggles on soldiers face
so they can be more effective and on the
Battleground and assist with training
scenarios and Microsoft won this
contract that could be worth nearly 22
billion dollars over the next 10 years
all right so how are things going with
that military contract there's been a
lot of back and forth in terms of
usability for soldiers I spoke with the
employees that worked on the project
that said it was very difficult for the
soldiers to use this device it was very
heavy on their head it created a lot of
eye strain they could only wear it for
short periods of time when they're
supposed to be wearing it for you know
hours 12 20 hours out in the field and
it just is not a practical device in
situations that are quite life and death
so there are some challenges to using it
what are things like internally within
the Halloween unit despite some you know
large corporate customers it's very
small volumes very low volumes you know
around 300 000 have been sold since it
came out in 2016. so in terms of a
business for a company the size of
Microsoft this is minuscule so it's
really been a challenge for them to
figure out the use cases and potentially
tap into big markets and also just
advancing the technology is very
challenging each generation maybe you'll
get a wider sort of field of view that
you can see this augmented reality stuff
but it is not a graceful sort of
consumer device it's not getting there
seemingly anytime soon and it's just a
huge huge cost for the company without a
ton of return
I mean given those struggles what is it
like for the people who work in the unit
employees feel quite frustrated for a
number of reasons I've spoken to many
employees current former over the past
year and there's been a lot of feeling
of lack of Direction being overworked
management at times has been troubling
and you know this is a company that was
very early on in this trend and they
have had a considerable amount of talent
that has left for places like apple and
meta trying to do their own smart
goggles what has Microsoft said about
all of this Microsoft they've said a lot
externally you can kind of see them
shift towards this idea that their
approach to what everyone is calling the
metaverse is software defined it is
software based rather than a hardware
based approach which is their hololens
products so they've certainly externally
backed away as far as what they've told
me they say they certainly have not said
that they're dropping out of Hardware
hololens just that their approach to the
metaverse that they call more broadly is
a variety of approaches they they have
Hardware they have software they have
gaming which touches on metaverse as
well so they say they're committed to it
and certainly not backing away so where
does Microsoft go with the hololens now
well they still have Enterprise
customers they're serving here they
still have this U.S military contract
but there was a much more ambitious plan
to address the consumer to try to create
this mass-market product and the company
it needs to focus in this time that you
know everybody's preparing for a
recession so they cut away a lot of that
ambition over the past year I think it
gets to the question of priorities the
company is very focused on its Cloud
business how much are they going to
prioritize a still very speculative
market and one thing about Microsoft in
its history is that they've always been
pretty good at seeing where technology
is going with new types of Hardware but
they never managed to execute on that as
well as a company like apple so I think
speaking with many folks kind of
reflected that reality that this is just
not in their DNA are there lessons then
that other companies that are making a
push into the metaverse should be taking
away from Microsoft's experience for
this to work there needs to be a broad
Market there needs to be a mass market
and how are customers going to be
motivated to put a headset on
that is a huge lift it has to be so good
it has to be better than the iPhone
better than a smartphone and so far no
one's cracked it all right that was our
reporter Aaron Tilley Aaron thanks so
much for joining us yeah thanks for
having me and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing if you want more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign